Adjacent to known reality lies an
infinite abyss of liminal spaces and
monstrous beings - The Backrooms. As with
all unusual and supernatural phenomena,
The SCP Foundation was set on cataloging the
Backrooms as an anomaly and finding a way to
contain it. But unfortunately, all it took was
one failed experiment for the opposite to occur.
Adjacent to known reality lies an infinite
abyss of liminal spaces and monstrous beings
- The Backrooms. As with all unusual and
supernatural phenomena, The SCP Foundation
was set on cataloging the Backrooms as an
anomaly and finding a way to contain it. But
unfortunately, all it took was one failed
experiment for the opposite to occur.
Sprinting through the maze towards the
smiler, SCP-096 was quickly too far away
for the Foundation staff to attempt recapture.
Moreover, this situation demanded a far more
immediate concern - there was no apparent
way to no-clip the lost portions of the site
back to native reality. The researchers,
D-class, and MTF personnel who were now
on the other side would have to adapt and
fend for themselves in this new reality.
Agent Cullen, the highest-ranked member
of the mobile task force present,
identified several hostile
entities approaching. These
bundles of arms were known as Clumps,
and since they did not possess eyes,
they had evaded 096’s wrathful response to
entities that saw its face. On Cullen’s orders,
the researchers and D-class took cover behind
the agents, who opened fire on the Clumps.
Meanwhile, SCP-096 caught up to the Smiler that
had glimpsed its face. In most cases, Smilers
are highly dangerous entities that prey on humans
who are trapped in the backrooms by pulling them
into the shadows. Because this was its nature,
the smiler was not prepared for 096 to not only
approach at top speed but to deliver a slamming
arm thrust straight into the creature’s face.
The smiler instantly knew that one more
blow like that would be the destruction
of its strange monstrous existence,
but it was too late to get away,
and 096 certainly didn’t stop at one. After
beating the smiler to a pulp, SCP-096 briefly
returned to a more neutral state of being. It
was not at all fazed by the new surroundings,
in fact, it was temporarily relieved
by the solitude of the Backrooms maze.
That was when SCP-096 felt the gaze of something
unknowably powerful staring at it from deeper
within the Backrooms dimensions. SCP-096 was no
stranger to being remotely viewed and becoming
enraged by it, but this was different. These
eyes were everywhere and nowhere all at once.
096 felt like it was being torn apart by its
own violent impulse to destroy whatever entity
was currently seeing its face. With no clear
target present, SCP-096 dropped to all fours,
and in an instant, it ran like a mad beast
through every conceivable corridor of the
infinite yellow maze in less than a single
second. During this blindingly fast rampage,
096 found itself back near the Foundation
personnel for a fraction of a moment.
None of the humans present could perceive the
shy guy at the hypersonic speed it was going,
but the result of it passing by was evident in
the abrupt death of several MTF agents who were
still focused on fending off the clumps. It was
collateral damage to 096, who didn’t intend for
its speeding body to collide with the agents, but
in any case, the clumps were at that much more of
an advantage when it came to brutally attacking
the members of the research team. The clumps'
numbers were increasing as well, as more of the
fleshy aberrations rolled forth from the woodwork.
One of the D-Class - D-3461 - panicked, breaking
away from the defensive line and bludgeoning an
MTF agent from behind. The others were still
reeling from the sudden slaughter created by
SCP-096, and were not quick enough to stop
D-3462 from turning tail and running off
into the maze with a stolen Mobile Task Force
issue firearm. The clumps seemed to ignore
this and focused on the larger group of humans
present, closing in well… a clump of clumps.
Senior researcher Dr. Hart - an expert
in reading the body language of anomalous
creatures - noticed this idiosyncratic movement
immediately. She immediately notified the
rest of the research team that the clumps
seemed to prioritize going after humans in
groups. As much as it was a cliche in horror
and adventure media, it seemed like the best
course of action was to split into groups
of two or three and run in all directions.
Without momentum, the clumps weren’t
especially fast, and given the sharp
turns and numerous crisscrossing
pathways of the Backrooms first level,
the humans could - with a head start
- keep themselves at a safe distance
if they used their brains and less
cumbersome limbs to maximum efficiency.
Dr. Hart chose her most trusted scientific
understudy, Dr. Whitaker as her retreat buddy,
and the two began to hurry down the many
hallways away from the clumps. If there
was a way to survive these entities, even on
their home terrain, it would be through the
superior intellect of the researchers. That is
what Dr. Hart believed in her doctor's heart.
She and the others who followed her plan were
lucky that 096 had stopped zooming through the
maze of the Backrooms first level. This was
because it realized that the entity or entities
which were looking at it was not here in this
dimension. Or rather, this level of the Backrooms.
But that didn’t mean that whatever it was
could hide for long, especially not from
SCP-096. The shy guy was capable of many things
when provoked by another being seeing its face,
and among the most obvious was its
nigh-invulnerability and extreme speed.
Both of these factors would come into play as
SCP-096 attempted a bizarre and fascinating feat.
The shy guy’s entire body shivered, vibrating
in place at an even faster velocity than it
had used to cross the infinite maze
in an instant moments prior. This
unorthodox psychics-straining movement
pattern made SCP-096 especially prone to
no-clipping - which was the only reliable
way to navigate between levels of the
backrooms. The sustained vibration was highly
damaging to 096’s body, but it felt no pain,
and the broken bones and frayed muscles
were returned to normal instantaneously.
Furiously and with no further preparation,
SCP-096 no-clipped through the floor of the
maze and began to descend through the known
levels of the backrooms towards the offending
entity that was still looking at its face.
Down one level, then two, then three…
The pressure of maintaining this feat would more
than likely kill or incapacitate any other being,
including many of SCP-096’s fellow
powerful anomalies. But that level
of endurance was what made SCP-096
so distinct and so unstoppable.
Four levels down. Five levels down.
As SCP-096 continued to descend,
the scattered personnel from the Foundation
were making their own discoveries about
no-clipping throughout the Backrooms.
D-3461 had found himself in a strange
new level of the back rooms filled with
sewer pipes and swooping death moths.
The rifle he had taken with him would
prove to be ample protection for now,
but he knew his ammunition wouldn’t be there
forever. Still, taking his chances sneaking around
down here felt better than trying to go back
towards anyone who knew him from the foundation.
Like most D-Class, D-3461, formerly known as
Gene Beatty, was a hardened criminal through and
through, and had done unforgivable things prior
to his time contained by the SCP Foundation. He
didn’t want to go back, not to the Foundation,
not to prison, and not even to the real world.
Forget ‘em all. He thought. He would
survive in this hellish abyss known
as Backrooms with only his malice and
sense of self-preservation to guide him.
Agent Cullen on the other hand, who was
accompanied by two of his surviving mobile
task force subordinates, was focused on
patrolling the yellow maze and searching
for potential human survivors. If other people
had been no-clipping into the Backrooms for as
long as the Foundation’s data suggested, it was
possible that enough of those unfortunates were
able to carve out a life for themselves that
a sizable faction had formed over the years.
Such a group would always have a need for
armed assistance and well-trained soldiers,
so Cullen knew he could easily find
himself a place among them. From there,
he would do everything in his
power to muster resources,
track down the scattered Foundation
personnel, and ultimately return home.
They have to be around here somewhere.
He told himself and his agents.
Of all the now hopelessly lost researchers, it
seemed that Dr. Hart and Dr. Whitaker had made it
the farthest into The Backrooms. They were both
now wandering in the Infinite Hotel - otherwise
known as Level 5 - a sprawling labyrinth
of suites and lobbies that would rival the
finest establishments in the front rooms
of reality. That is, if it were not also
full of the same kind of hostile entities
that were so common through the backrooms.
Dr. Whitaker attempted to stay in high spirits,
however, making a sophomoric joke about needing
a “vacation from his vacation.” Dr. Hart groaned,
but on some level, she was grateful to have
her younger and more eccentric colleague close
by. Though he lacked common sense, he was
a prodigy at science, and more than that,
he was loyal. The two of them would need teamwork
and perseverance to keep going in this place,
and through her mentorship of the young
man, the groundwork was already there.
He and I will manage somehow.
Dr. Hart affirmed in her mind.
Elsewhere, several levels down,
SCP-096 had arrived at the source
of the strange gaze that had been fixed
upon it. In level 11 of the backrooms:
the city - which fittingly enough resembled a
modern human city of vast proportions - SCP-096
was found locked onto the entity known
as Argos - entity 74 - an ancient eyeless
humanoid whose vision was pervasive and
near-omniscient throughout the backrooms.
The cruel and judgemental being could observe the
sins of any sentient creature that entered the
backrooms and would carry out a brutal punishment
accordingly. This was its routine behavior,
and it didn’t single out SCP-096 anymore than it
did D-3461 - whose sins were much more severe in
the eyes of Argos due to the ill intent behind
them. That is not to say that Argos saw the shy
guy as innocent. Even out of perceived defense,
the amount of lives that SCP-096 had taken was,
on principle, enough to call even
the most well-meaning being a sinner.
A fight between Argos and the shy guy
was inevitable. Argos was accompanied
by several scores of spear-wielding warriors
in tactical gear - human explorers who had
joined his cause. They would prove
to be little more than speed bumps,
as 096 made skid marks out of them on its way
to pummel the everloving snot out of Argos.
But Argos was not going to allow
the sacrifices of his “eyes” to be
in vain. The entity used the reach of
his spear to strike 096 at a distance,
impaling the creature in mid-run to the ground.
This held the shy guy for all but a moment before
it moved its body up the spear and slammed
into Argos, throwing the two of them through
a nearby building. Argos fought desperately to
remove his spear from his opponent's body as
all the while 096 pounded him with punches that
could each reduce an automobile to scrap metal.
The two interlocked monsters tumbled
through wall after wall of the skyscraper,
taking the lives of several unlucky
human citizens in the process. When
Argos pried his spear free from 096, he
immediately jumped back several paces,
but once again, he had underestimated the
shy guy who was at his throat in seconds.
Passersby on the street watched in horror
as 096 hurled Argos by the throat into the
skyscraper directly across from the one
they had been fighting in. Argos crashed
through the glass of the windows and into
an office floor. One titanic leap from the
shy guy later, and 096 had joined
Argos on this new fighting stage.
Argos twirled his spear in a frenzied
display of combat prowess. If this thing
insisted on advancing towards him
with no regard for its well-being,
it would have to go through his spear multiple
times over. But 096 was not the kind to let fear
stop it from advancing. It charged, taking
every attack Argos could dish out before
pummeling him downward through several floors of
the building until they reached the ground level.
SCP-096 could have taken far more punishment,
but Argos had reached his limit. The entity’s
spear fell from his hand as 096 continued to
hit harder and harder, over and over again,
until Argos was as close to death as
an immortal backrooms entity could be.
At the very least, he had been injured so severely
that his all-seeing gaze had become weakened.
For the shy guy, this meant that Argos was
technically no longer looking at it. It
became docile once more and wandered out
of the building into the streets. To its
relief and to the relief of the nearby
entities, the facelings of this city
had no eyes and no interest in looking
at 096, preferring to continue their
mindless pantomime of normative life.
Aren’t we all, in a cosmic sense?
Regardless, SCP-096 walked through the streets
of the city with one goal: return home. But home
was far, far, away from where the shy guy was,
and the no-clipping maneuver that it performed
earlier was not something that the anomaly
could muster the recklessness to do at all
times. Only when its face was glimpsed did
SCP-096 possess its murderous determination.
At the moment, SCP-096 was like a morning jogger,
traveling through Level 11 at a brisk pace and
searching for a way out. This naturally led
the anomaly towards the suburban neighborhoods,
which were themselves an entrance
to The Backrooms Level 9 - Suburbia.
It was here on the dark streets of the
limitless suburbs that 096 encountered
a new nightmare - The Neighborhood
Watch. Comprised of a series of
hostile entities resembling - in part -
human eyeballs, these ocular adversaries
were known to patrol suburbia and keep
the peace… by eliminating all intruders,
of course. The floating watchers were capable of
shooting disintegration beams, while the towering
striders possessed sinewy limbs that could
easily bash most entities into submission.
But… unfortunately for everyone involved -
they were giant eyeballs. One look from the
Neighborhood Watch in the direction of SCP-096
and their fates were sealed. Being ogled by
humongous eyeballs was simply more than the shy
guy could take. With a primal screech, it ran
towards the oversized peepers with a massacre on
its mind. A few of the watchers had time to fire
disintegration blasts, which slowed the approach
of SCP-096, but it was too little too late.
SCP-096 smashed into the strider, knocking
it to the ground and delivering a crushing
blow to its pupil. Without missing a beat,
SCP-096 leaped into the air and smashed one
of the watchers against a charming
suburban home. The shy guy rampage
would continue until there were no more
eyes on it, in the Backrooms or anywhere.
Now check out “SCP-096 VS SCP-343”
and “SCP-096’s Sad END!” for more!